let me start with uh congratulations on
your show I saw the first three episodes
I very much am looking forward to seeing
how it all goes thank you um it's not
too often you introduce a character on a
series by and pardon my language by
pissing literally that is how we are
introduced to your character when you
read that in the script or you're like
oh this is my kind of show this is my
kind of show that is from the first piss
I knew it
being serious
um what was it about the material that
actually said I totally need to do this
yeah I mean one I just I I really love
the way that Alexi decided to tell the
story I felt like there was this like
comedic timing to the whole thing and
there was also these like high stakes
and this drama to it and suspense that I
I liked I love the character of Owen I
just kind of liked his his attitude and
his ability to be like super selfish and
like run through and have no idea what
he's doing at all
um and then try to figure it out along
the way
um I liked how it was the Spy genre but
through the lens of a kid that just
graduated law school and went to the CIA
as a lawyer and he's balancing that home
life right it's not just all he's not a
spy he's a lawyer but then he has to act
like a spy and constantly have to
reevaluate his life decisions and
choices yeah there's a lot to it Doug
Lyman being involved was a big part of
it too
um you know I
I've been wanting to work with Doug for
for so long so I jumped at the
opportunity that's something that
actually I that struck me about the
episodes I watched is that it wasn't
what I expected it was uh like a it was
like a like not a reboot but like a
remix of things that maybe that have
been done before but in a new way
um and I totally want to focus on Doug
Lyman I am a big fan he directed the
first two episodes and he's very
interesting the way he works on set
because he likes finding things in the
moment and so can you sort of talk about
that especially the first two episodes
yeah absolutely I think you know he's
Doug
I love it when he grabs the camera
because he's an incredible camera
operator and you can really see his
fingerprint in the fight scenes right
like it's very reminiscent of born Mr
Mrs Smith I mean all of his films right
it has it has that that that Doug Lyman
feel to it
um
and what he's so good at I think is like
one of the things that I really really
noticed was when he gives a note he
reminds you of the stakes of the
situation that's his note
um
you know and uh and yeah I don't know it
was just I felt like we got along very
very well and we're able it felt like we
were playing jazz on set we had this
like kind of unspoken language you know
we'd finish a take and you'd go and
right of course and he's like right good
guy and like that was how we
communicated for the first two episodes
pretty much uh there's a scene where
you're swimming in a uh real River
um at least I believe it is oh yeah I'm
like you never know with Hollywood magic
um uh so when they told you you were
doing that because obviously you can't
contain that River it's the river were
you like oh please God no or were you
like oh I'm in Soda super down Douglas
too we both Doug and I both got into the
river yeah it was in Vienna yeah we jump
in uh out of the boat we jump out of the
boat into it he's got the camera on a
boogie board
um and we just shot and then they pull
us into the boat we go back to the top
because it was a pretty intense current
as well and you jump back in jump in and
then action there you go
um that was something that I think we
both loved is we both got to really
engage you got to work with Dwayne
obviously on Black Adam
um I think some people might have seen
it uh one of the things that I really
respect about Dwayne is his work ethic
onset super professional and I'm curious
what did you learn working with Dwayne
as it like the way he conducts himself
that you've taken with you to your
future projects and you know what I mean
absolutely the man is prepared to the T
when he's on set
um he rolls with it with a team of
people around him that he's crafted he's
hand-picked that are all so
so able to execute the entire vision and
everyone is aligned on the vision and I
think that was something that I picked
up on and tried to learn from at the
very least
the Duty's so prepared so prepared on
set knows the work knows everybody
else's lines pretty much in their
character stories and it helps inform
his own and how he plays into it and um
I think you know I took that to heart
when we're up in Montreal and just tried
to do my very best in that regard as
well
um I definitely have to ask you if
you've spoken to James Gunn yet because
obviously him and Peter have gotten some
keys to the castle
are you trying to hit him in the DMS oh
yeah I dm'd him I shot him I sent a
carrier pigeon for his home one of the
things with the series obviously is
Netflix is hoping it's going to be a hit
you're hoping it's going to be a hit
what are you hoping to have happen if
you get to make a second season or a
third season yeah I mean the goal is
always to make something that people
like and enjoy and want more of so if
that were to happen there would be
phenomenal
um
and I just want to see the characters
grow more I think we established some
incredible characters like Christian
brunsianus I love him and vandi and even
the roommates right like Fievel and Dana
knows characters I just want to see
everybody kind of grow and develop and
deepen as well
um I want to introduce maybe uh other
cases that Owen has to work on
simultaneously that could be really cool
although this one certainly is not
finished by the by the ending so there's
a lot of different directions that we
could go in uh you got to work I believe
with Jackie Chan I did years ago
um I just want to know what it was like
him as a director was fantastic he
he's obviously an actor and like he has
done hundreds of movies so his ability
when he's directing was from the actor's
perspective and he would tell you
exactly what he needed he would actually
give you the performance that he wanted
you to okay he's that kind of director
no but it was great it's Jackie Chan in
front of you you know he's like yeah at
this part sad and then when this happens
happy and then oh back and run and
you're like I will do exactly that as
you just did it first of all that I've
interviewed Jackie and that's you're not
far off
um with that so we're here at people
can't tell but we're at ccxp hell yeah
Brazil baby exactly so um I I'm not sure
you probably flew in like a day ago do
you get to actually enjoy any aspect or
is it like you're living the musician
lifestyle where like you arrive you're
in the you know what I mean yeah yeah I
know exactly what you mean I feel like
I've gone to two restaurants here which
were fantastic so I got to experience
um some of the food here they were very
like they were like Michelin star
restaurants so they weren't like the the
like Mom and Pop sure I think uh that I
that I love so much but they were
fantastic it was great to see that side
of the city
um but no it's more so musician I think
outside of like going to those
restaurants I've just been in the hotel
yeah I would like to come back for
vacation or something and really explore
properly on that note I gotta go
um seriously congrats on the show thank
you hope it's a huge hit thank you so
much